okay fine I'll talk about this fight
[Music]
so yeah everyone
talks about this fight as the best
animation in all of Dragon Ball Z and
that's for a good reason Studio cockpit
the crew that animated this episode are
absolute Legends the cellophyte is
probably not the only place you know
them from either they also did this
episode with Goku facing Kid Buu as you
can see between just those two episodes
their focus is on Dynamic movement
active choreography and very expressive
faces among their rank stands three
Giants ksk Matsunaga masaki iwone and
yoshihiko umakoshi these three with the
rest of their Studio peers produce some
of the most iconic Dragon Ball Z
episodes to ever exist if there is a
clip of Z where all the comments are
saying things like this is the best
episode of the whole show and the art
style is the best ever Etc you can make
a pretty good bet it's Studio cockpit